[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanto è importante la cultura aziendale
all'interno di un'impresa e quant'è
importante per il business di
quell'impresa
ora vi diranno tutti che è importante è
evidente in realtà è il come che fa la
differenza e oggi cercherò in questi
dodici minuti e di raccontarvi quanto la
cultura è stata importante nel bene e
nel male per microsoft
per farlo però bisogna fare un viaggio
nel passato 4 aprile 1975 due ragazzi
giovani di 20 anni so cosa state
pensando quello di sinistra salvare il
padre dicono di destra ma hanno tutti e
due vent'anni bill gates e paul allen in
un garage del della famiglia gates
scrivono e il loro primo software un
software che cambierà il mondo hanno un
piccolo problema non esiste il computer
per far girare per software dei grandi
imprese hanno i mainframe
stiamo parlando in periodo in cui non
c'era inter non ci sono i smartphone in
italia non era ancora arrivata la
televisione a colori e loro avevano un
software che volevano vendere ma il
mondo non aveva i pc
allora si immaginano di vedere un pc su
ogni scrivania e decidono di costruire
un'azienda di software discutono sul
nome e b che si dice beh ma noi facciamo
software
siamo in due siamo piccoli chiamiamoci
micro soft e da lì nasce microsoft che
oggi è una realtà che fa più di 110
miliardi all'anno di fatturato a 120
imprese saeed era in tutto il mondo più
di 100.000 dipendenti 120mila dipendenti
come è possibile
com'è possibile che due ragazzi siano
state in grado di costruire un'azienda
di questo tipo talento si intelligenza
si fortuna anche ma a quel tempo c'erano
delle aziende già nel mercato
informatico
a quel tempo c'erano delle aziende
strutturate
per guardare quell'opportunità perché
non hanno guardata perché non l'hanno
vista una questione di cultura non è una
questione di intelligenza non una
questione di talento una questione di
immaginare di essere invincibili e ci
arriviamo ad un certo punto mai cosa ha
deciso di costruire prodotti prodotti
che voi conoscete probabilmente tutti
quanti avete usato almeno una volta
nella nostra vita office windows
oggi abbiamo il cloud abbiamo anche dei
prodotti che i nostri utenti
adorano mi piace la foto a sinistra a
destra del ragazzo innamorato dell'xbox
no questo microsoft fa questo primo è
quello che ha fatto microsoft in tanti
anni che cosa si erano perse quelle
grandi aziende si erano perse le
opportunità non avevano guardato fuori
non avevano capito il mercato che cosa
aveva da offrire
si erano sedute sulla propria
innovazione sul proprio business sui
propri numeri sulla propria burocrazia e
alcune di quelle aziende che 40 anni fa
erano fortissime non esistono più per
aver perso quell'opportunità e questa
cosa è capitata anche a microsoft è
capitata anche a noi siamo viaggiati
attraverso lo stesso problema il fatto
che io sia qui significa che ne siamo
usciti
ma questo è un altro discorso ma siamo
passati attraverso lo stesso viaggio
perché perché abbiamo fatto un sacco di
errori negli ultimi 15 anni ci siamo
persi tante opportunità prima nel 1997
mi ricordo che avevo in mano il primo
smartphone microsoft
nessuno al mondo aveva ancora prodotto
uno smartphone
oggi microsoft non è nel business line
al phon
come è possibile se qualcun altro che
tutti noi conosciamo tablet
stessa cosa 1999 primo tablet in italia
microsoft
oggi c'è qualcun altro che domina nel
mondo dei tablet internet
pensiamo ad internet i motori di ricerca
ma che cosa è stata la prima a lanciare
microsoft network ora non se lo filava
nessuno ma era microsoft network perché
abbiamo perso tutte queste battaglie
perché abbiamo perso questa opportunità
queste opportunità hanno creato aziende
da zero anche aussie oggi sono
miliardari è semplicemente per il fatto
che arrivavamo arrivati ad un punto in
cui il talento all'interno dell'azienda
veniva offuscato da una cultura
aziendale che impediva di vedere fuori
una cultura aziendale che impediva di
guardare alle opportunità di rendere
un'azienda agile di premiare il rischio
di premiare il fallimento facevamo del
business lo facevamo bene crescevamo
ogni anno le azioni saliva perché c'era
bisogno di guardare altro e abbiamo
perso grandi opportunità ora che cosa è
successa una cosa molto molto
interessante quattro anni fa al posto di
steve ballmer viene eletto un nuovo ceo
satya nadella che non è un grande
imprenditore che viene dall'esterno non
è un cielo che noi abbiamo rubato da
altre aziende è una persona che sa ben
26 anni prima entra in microsoft come
sviluppatore e comincia a fare la sua
carriera all'interno di microsoft
lo chiamano un giorno e gli dicono tu
sei il nuovo ceo di microsoft e lui ha
vissuto 26 anni in quell azienda e ha
capito che non era la mancanza di
talenti all'interno dell'azienda che
aveva in qualche maniera rallentato la
crescita di mike sono meno mancanza di
intelligenza né di prodotti
era una mancanza di cultura aziendale
allora che cosa fa la prima cosa che fa
quando entra in microsoft cambia per
primo
tutto nel modo in cui lui si comporta
con il segno leggerci team lui si
comporta con i dipendenti i messaggi che
racconta la prima cosa che sa ti ha
fatto il giorno dopo che è stato
nominato ceo è stata una cosa che
nessuno aveva avuto mai il coraggio di
fare
precedentemente ha lanciato office per
iphone ora da fuori sembra beh hai
lanciato un'applicazione su un
telefonino che cosa sarà mai di così
grande e buffi sera per noi l'unico
valore che aveva windows
quindi era un asset importante ma ha
deciso di cambiare le regole del gioco
un anno fa ha scritto questo libro che
si chiama i tre flash in cui racconta la
sua evoluzione e gli ostacoli che ha
incontrato ho preso tre frasi importanti
del suo libro la prima che la seguente
ad un certo punto arrivi ad avere
un'azienda talmente tanto che guarda
dentro che non riesce più a guardare
fuori talmente tanto in annegata nella
politica dei gruppi dei soldi delle
revenue che ti fai il perdere delle
opportunità la seconda che c'è bisogno
ogni tanto di fare le frecce il libro si
chiama it refresh perché ovviamente lui
essendo una persona tecnica i tre flash
quando voi schiacciate f5 sul browser
far refresh della pagina
questo è il principio la terza la più
importante è fermarsi un attimo a
riflettere ma la missione di microsoft
quale era i dipendenti la conoscevano
partecipavano alla missione di microsoft
e allora decide di cambiarla e crea
questa missione
ogni parola ha un suo peso ogni parola
la sua importanza è una missione che lui
racconta in ogni speech che fa da
quattro anni a questa parte in ogni
momento la prima slime è la missione di
microsoft aiutare aziende ed in dvd a
fare di più con la tecnologia sembra una
missione molto semplice ma molto
profonda che racconta un po la nuova
microsoft un mese fa un ragazzo stava
facendo un tour all'interno di
università un ragazzo alza la mano e gli
dice ma voi che assumete i talenti che
cercate
che tipo di persone cercate all'interno
di microsoft e la sua risposta è stata
molto molto efficace ha detto se vuoi
essere cool non venire a lavorare in
microsoft
se vuoi rendere gli altri cool microsoft
è la scelta giusta
e solo questione di cultura
e deciso di cambiarla poi si è fermato
un attimo ha detto io la missione cielo
è chiara la racconto o persone
intelligenti o persone di talento che
cosa mi manca mi manca la giusta cultura
aziendale
mi manca lasciare lo spazio alle persone
di fallire un anno fa noi un anno e
mezzo fa abbiamo rilasciato un primo
chatbot dei robot a cui io posso fare
delle domande e che mi diano delle
risposte attraverso l'intelligenza
artificiale
ora dopo dieci giorni di uso di questo
jackpot le risposte del chatbot
cominciavano essere pericolose razziste
sbagliate
il cibo insultava le persone che
facevano le domande nella vecchia
microsoft le persone responsabili di
quel shampoo sarebbero state
probabilmente allontanate dell'azienda
la prima cosa che stati affatto ha
mandato una mail a tutti i dipendenti
con i loro into the cendo avete fatto un
grande lavoro avete fallito ma dai
fallimenti si impara continuerete a
lavorare e 6 mesi fa abbiamo rilasciato
la seconda versione del softball che per
fortuna funziona correttamente è un
cambio di cultura importante perché la
cultura si mangia la strategia a
colazione ed è importante comprenderlo
perché lui è quello che fa ogni giorno è
interessante vi racconto un aneddoto
prima riunione di satyam all'interno del
leadership team si presentano tutti i
leader delle divisioni intorno al tavolo
con centinaia di fogli con tutti i
numeri dei business divisi per prodotto
segmento e lui riguarda il vice cosa
cosa mi state facendo vedere e parliamo
di business
no qui non si parla di business qui si
parla di voi che si parla di come state
di come sta la vostra di visione di come
vi sentite appartenere a microsoft si
parla di qualcosa che non c'entra niente
con i prodotti e le tecnologie ma si
parla di come trasformare un'azienda
fixed mindset in un'azienda roma
insensati alegi un di un libro di carol
durc che una psicologa statunistense
dell'università di stanford che per anni
ha studiato questo 2 atteggiamento
vela semplifico la calo al great dice sì
l'intelligenza importante ma il man 7
più importante ha fatto tanti
esperimenti sui ragazzi cercando di
capire quanto la volontà di imparare la
capacità di fallire di risalire dal
fallimento la voglia di apprendere nuove
cose non pensare di essere intelligenti
lui ci dice sempre sentire una stanza e
pensi di essere il più intelligente
della stanza è sbagliato stanza di
ricercare una stanza in cui tu non sei
il più intelligente e ha tentato di
raccontarci questa storia per aiutare
tutte le persone di microsoft dal board
fino all'ultimo dipendente a prendere
coraggio a fare delle cose che prima
erano impensabili prendersi il rischio
di fallire recuperare dal fallimento
imparare riprovare di nuovo fino a
quando un'idea deve essere veramente
innovativa e che cosa è successo
esattamente il primo luglio del 2017
ci sono due numeri importanti 48.000 e
uno il primo luglio nel 2017 48.000
persone all'interno di microsoft in un
giorno hanno cambiato ruolo mestiere
manager e divisione in un giorno senza
fare sconti al business senza pensare di
dire noi non ci fermiamo per un anno
perché dovremmo cambiare organizzazione
no
i numeri devono arrivare sempre ma io
cambio metà dell'organizzazione aneddoto
personale il 30 giugno del 2007 faceva
un mestiere completamente diversa e fino
al 30 giugno non sapevo nulla
per me il mondo era quello ero pronto a
partire con un nuovo anno con lo stesso
ruolo mi chiama il mio capo
l'amministrato delegato di mike sony
dice sì ed i tempi ti ricordo di mister
e che hai fatto fino a ieri
dimenticatelo il tuo nuovo mestiere
questo questo il team questo l'obiettivo
vai questa cosa è avvenuta per 48 mila
persone vuol dire prendersi dei rischi
enormi vuol dire accettare il fallimento
ma quando satya è entrato in microsoft
azioni di microsoft valeva 27 dollari
oggi dopo quattro anni valle 114
di dollari soprattutto per il cambio di
cultura e per averci dato la possibilità
di fallire
vi lascio con una slide di un atleta che
conoscete tutti di cui sappiamo le gesta
sui campi di basket
contiamo le vittorie ma quello che lui
dice tutti i fallimenti che io ho fatto
mi hanno fatto diventare la persona di
successo che sono per cui buon
fallimento a tutti quanti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]